karl lauterbach das ist eine komische
situation sie haben persönlich nie von
100.000 instanzen pro tag gesprochen und
auch nicht von 300 im durchschnitt aber
sie haben von 200 gesprochen würden sich
selber sagen dass auch sie einer
derjenigen war die übertrieben haben mit
der angst nahm übertrieben also habe ich
nicht und ich glaube auch die
kolleginnen und kollegen die eben
angesprochen worden sind die haben auch
nicht übertrieben
ich habe diese sehr hohen zahl nicht für
realistisch gehalten und zwar deshalb
weil in modellen wird maßen so einen
selbst bremseffekt nicht mit modellierte
eintritt wenn die leute hören was
wirklich also sagen weil die stunde
geschlagen hat werden dann vorsichtiger
das hat gewirkt und das hatte ich also
sagen wir mal antizipiert ich hatte mit
dirk brockmann und wenn meier ein modell
gemacht wo das auch mit drin war
und das sieht man also immer diese
zahlen wie entwickelt es sich wenn
nichts passiert dass sie dann unfassbar
dramatisch aus und was passiert also
werden sich die bevölkerung vorsichtiger
verhält was passiert wenn man zusätzlich
auch noch maßnahmen ergreift und was
passiert wenn man zusätzliche und jetzt
haben sie im grunde alles genannt was
passiert ist wenn die leute haben sich
sofort angenommen halten es brauchte
also nicht die bundes notbremse doch die
braucht es schon sehen die ihr dann auch
es vier wochen später kann ich glaube es
sind insgesamt fünf effekte gewesen also
wie gewirkt haben zunächst einmal als
wir über diese oster ruhe diskutiert da
ist ganz klar geworden also durch die
aufgeregte diskussion die stattfand
übereinander notsituation daran die
menschen schon angefangen sich ganz
anders zu verhalten die haben sich
ostern anders verhalten also sonst
passiert wäre dann ist diese drastische
diskussion in der wissenschaft gekommen
als die oster ruhe nicht kam
und dann das impfen genau dann ist
sozusagen sind die mich noch
vorsichtiger geworden dann das imk hat
die wenigste gespielt dann ist
tatsächlich durch die vorbereitung der
notbremse sind die lockerungen nicht
bekommen die sonst gekommen wäre dann
kam die eigentliche notbremsen die hat
auch gestärkt wird und dann kam ein vor
effekt des impfens und wir wissen aus
studien aus england dass die menschen
die kurz vor der impfung sind sich
deutlich vorsichtiger verhalten sollen
daher da diese fünf effekte plus die
impfung aber die hat das gesagt das
wenigste bisher gemacht das würde sie
mal richtig
diese fünf effekte haben
sich anderes also wetter und impfungen
nennen jetzt andere
wissenschaftskollegen auch noch da sind
sie ein bisschen zurückhaltend einen
neben ihnen sitzt völlig zurecht alena
büxt die chefin des deutschen ethikrates
frau bog sie haben die diskussionen
natürlich auch verfolgt wie keine andere
und wissen dass sich kluge menschen zu
wort gemeldet haben die darauf
aufmerksam machten
da ist viel mit angst gearbeitet worden
juli zeh meldete sich zu wort andere
autoren auch schlaue menschen dieses
landes die sagte es wäre toll gewesen
wenn der bund auch ein bisschen mehr
geliefert hätte zu der art alarm die
ständig gemacht wurde es hängt von euch
ab was jetzt passiert ist hängt von euch
ab was jetzt passiert haben sie das auch
empfunden dass es irgendwie doch ein
recht maßgeblicher dauer alarmismus war
der ich würde es nicht als dauer
alarmismus bezeichnen aber was glaube
ich schon vielen gefehlt hat war auch
eine positive vision dabei angst ist
auch relevant gewesen es ist auch
richtig wenn man sorge hat dass das
gesundheitswesen überwältigt sein könnte
dann angst zu haben
aber um diese jetzt inzwischen lange
zeit in der auch phasen waren wo alle
irgendwo den eindruck an da passiert
jetzt so gar nicht so richtig
das baut sehr viel frust auf unter
braucht man und das sieht man auch in
befragungen an die bevölkerung da
braucht man eine vision da braucht man
hier das gefühl man wird eher positiv
durchgeführt da gibt es ein ziel auf das
es hingehen und dann wird es auch wieder
besser und ich glaube das hat viele ganz
schön angefasst und einfach auch
ausgelaugt und ist für viele immer
schwerer gemacht das auszuhalten und ich
kann das sehr gut nachvollziehen
volker bouffier ist bei uns
ministerpräsident des schönen landes
hessens darüber freuten wir uns
natürlich sehr
es ist eine ganz naheliegende frage herr
bouffier weil sie auch nie mit kritik
zurückhaltend waren hat die politik in
ihren augen genug getan um den menschen
auch aus der angst heraus zu helfen
es ist ein
wie soll ich sagen die politik ist schon
schwierig ich glaube zu verstehen was
sie meinen also die die jetzt ämter
wahrnehmen und eine entscheidung treffen
müssen und wir haben es ja eben gehört
und ich will zwei punkte mal sagen wir
haben ja schon vor der bundesnotarkammer
gemacht
wir haben permanent eingeschränkt also
die fünf punkte kollege lauterbach
gesagt das ist in ordnung aber das muss
man sagen wir haben für euch und eine
ganze menge gemacht das stimmt und das
was doch jeder versteht die menschen
sind müde ich habe schon mal an anderer
stelle gesagt sie haben die schnauze
voll
sie wollen jetzt wissen okay jetzt macht
noch zwei wochen zu haben noch drei
wochen aber dann dann können wir doch
wieder aufmacht das war immer eine
fehlvorstellung das hat man so
inspiriert und deshalb ich will daran
erinnern
ostern weihnachten vor weihnachten wurde
gesagt um gottes willen an weihnachten
werden sich alle treffen das wird einen
kick geben
die menschen waren vernünftig ist nicht
passiert nach weihnachten sind wir sehr
deutlich runter gekommen
sehr deutlich überall dann kamen die
britische variante
und plötzlich ging es wieder hoch die
hatte die politik vorher auch nicht im
blick und wir sind ein stück weit
natürlich immer auch in der situation
dass wir uns neue sachverhalte ja nicht
einfach ignorieren können wenn uns die
wissenschaft sagt passt mal auf die
modellierer das geht auf 34 100 gott sei
dank ist es nie gesehen das ist gut
darüber können wir uns freuen und das
ist ein zusammenwirken
aber richtig ist auch politiker nicht
zaubern sie müssen abwägen was ist am
ende
verantwortbar sie können nicht die
intensivmediziner die verkürzung uns
jeden tag jeden tag beginnt haben gesagt
machen sie dichtmachen sie dicht das war
nicht vor vier oder acht wochen das war
noch vor zwei wochen
und das kann man nicht ignorieren auf
der anderen seite die vielfachen nicht
nur wünsche sondern begründeten
erwartungen dass die menschen sagen
jetzt sag mir mal wann kann ich wieder
meinen lagen auf war das so völlig
verständlich dass immer wieder abzuwägen
und ich bin sehr vorsichtig mit
versprechungen
was wir aber am ende holt aus
fragen können unabhängig ob diese bundes
notbremse das hätten wir alles anders
organisieren können aber ist jetzt mal
egal
bisher kann die noch gar keine große
wirkung entfaltet haben von dem
infektionszahlen er aber wichtig ist
doch dass intel hat drastisch zugenommen
das ist gut und wir haben eine
perspektive und das will ich gerne sagen
den menschen sagen passt auf wir machen
das jetzt nicht noch acht mal so nach
dem motto wenn sie jetzt noch einen
monat dann noch in hand gehe fest davon
aus dass wir bis zum juli den
allergrößten teil durchgekämpft haben
und in der zweiten impfung dann kurz
haben den august noch dazu nehmen und
das wird dann zu einem guten teil zu
unserem leben wieder zu weil es die
eigene halle die eigentliche rettung in
dieser pandemie ist dass wir eine
impfung haben dass die menschen sich
impfen können ist für sie genauso
interessant herr bouffier dass wir wie
im märz des letzten jahres auch diesmal
wieder sagen können
die menschen haben vorher ihr verhalten
verändert sie haben vorher verstanden
dass die bilder aus brasilien nicht
schön sind sie haben vorher verstanden
was die intensivmediziner gesagt haben
und sofort was sagt ihnen das wenn die
menschen so selbstverantwortlich handeln
dass ich das so an gehe ich bin zutiefst
davon überzeugt sie können ein
freiheitliches land nicht mit
verordnungen gesetze und ähnlichem auf
dauer regieren
und wenn die leute dann sich nicht daran
halten am ende mit der
bereitschaftspolizei versuchen oder sich
dann halten das wird nichts werden
wir werden nur erfolgreich sein wenn die
menschen aus eigener überzeugung seien
für sich und ihre familie ja das ist
richtig wenn ich so verhalte und die
meisten menschen verhalten sich ja auch
so es darf man ja nicht vergessen und
das ist ein großes glück ich halte
nichts davon dass man so die bevölkerung
mit kleine kinder werden nach dem motto
jetzt wenn er nicht hört dann machen wir
noch vier wochen sondern den bürger als
partner und diejenigen die sich nur an
gar nichts halten die müssen natürlich
dann auch mit den mitteln des
ordnungsrechts zur ordnung gerufen
werden und zusammen mit sal
sie klingen jetzt ein bisschen wie armin
laschet sie würden aber nicht noch mal
sagen herr bouffier wie im märz
jeder der behauptet das hätte man alles
schon vor wochen wissen müssen
mit sowas will ich mich gar nicht aus
wir setzen also wissenschaftler haben
sie schon gewarnt davor dass es
mutationen gibt und dass diese
mutationen eben erst recht besonders
gefährlich werden und dass sie im winter
kommen
darauf sind sie rechtzeitig genug
hingewiesen worden wenn sie es noch mal
so sagen das würde ich nicht akzeptieren
nehmen sie die heutige debatte niemand
weiß was im halben jahr ist mit hingabe
wird darüber diskutiert wie lange hält
denn der impfstoff an müssen wir nicht
vielleicht zum dritten mal das weiß
niemand
also müssen wir doch darauf zurückziehen
dass wir sagen wir haben eine situation
die hatten wir noch nie
ja aber trotzdem und deshalb und das
nehme ich schon für uns in anspruch alle
und deshalb müssen wir offen sein für
neue wissenschaftliche erkenntnisse und
zwar und mit verlaub auch bei den
virologen haben wir eine sehr breite
meinung breit ganz unterschiedlicher art
und ich bin nicht dafür da zu sagen der
erträge oder der trick ich versuche
abzuwägen was ist am ende verantwortbar
und ich möchte dass die menschen aus
eigener einsicht sich an die regeln
halten und dass wir so schnell wir
können jeden ihr normales leben zu geben
das ist der uns wirklich immunität
fragen wer karl lauterbach gleich liegen
möchte unbedingt kati witt noch in der
runde vorstellen olympiasieger
schauspielerin moderatorin und man kennt
sie hielten nach vorne und nach hinten
und unternehmerin es sie auch die wirte
letzte woche noch alles dicht machen
jetzt alles auf machen sind sie hinter
gm kommen sind sie mit mitgekommen
wir sind eigentlich immer noch dicht
also der sport ist für neun monate schon
geschlossen und ich bin eher auch hier
weil ich möchte wirklich für den sport
kämpfen wir hatten uns vorhin schon ein
bisschen ausgetauscht
es geht um breitensport es geht um den
sport für kinder und jugendliche meiner
meinung nach geht gesundheit nicht ohne
aktiven sport das geht nur hand in hand
und ich finde es ist eigentlich
überhaupt nicht mehr verhandelbar ob
sport aufgemacht wird oder sport zu
gemacht wird sport gehört zu unserem
leben sport muss für die kinder für
spanien für die erwachsenen für die
ältere generation
das ist wie zähneputzen das ist
körperpflege ja so dass irgendwie der
hund und ich kenne eigentlich dafür dass
der sport diesen stellen
wert innerhalb der gesellschaft bekommt
abgesehen davon natürlich ist es ein
großer wirtschaftszweig
aber diejenigen die sich wirklich
entschieden haben einen
gesundheitscenter ein spender ein
fitnesscenter zu öffnen zu den verein zu
gehen ehrenamtlich als trainer tätig zu
sein als übungsleiter die eltern die
sich engagieren die machen das aus liebe
und überzeugung zum spott was nämlich
der spott für die gesundheit bedeutet
und was der sport auch als erziehung
beziehung des werte die man mitbekommt
ein ende ein monolog es ist eine
wunderbar ein wunderbarer gedanke der
dem sich natürlich viele menschen auch
anschließend nur sind wir jetzt in
dieser blöden pandemie und es gibt immer
noch orte die haben eine inzidenz von
über 500 und es gibt orte wie potsdam da
sieht es jetzt schon ein bisschen besser
aus ihr seid bei 118 glaube ich so also
wann kann man ich weiß dass sie sich
sehr engagieren auch in thüringen
beispielsweise in der modellstadt wann
kann man denn in ihren augen mit einer
guten idee mit einem guten gene konzept
auch wieder mit kunden rechnen die sich
was traut
ja ich finde da haben sie das richtig
gesagt mit den bürgern mit uns also wir
fühlen uns auch zum großen teil
ausgeschlossen also gerade wenn ich über
im sportstudio oder fitnessstudio rede
wir haben doch alle verantwortung oder
wir werden lange zeit nicht in ein
normales leben zurückfinden wenn sie
jetzt schon vor waren vielleicht gibt es
die dritte mutante das heißt wir müssen
ja langfristig denken langfristig wie
können wir vernünftig verantwortungsvoll
mit hygienemaßnahmen öffnungs konzepte
haben es gibt modelle ideen die
natürlich alle wieder eingefroren werden
ich habe es hier bei mir auf facebook
gefeiert weil sie sie waren der erste
ministerpräsident
pünktlich zum frauentag am 8 märz haben
sie die sportstudios geöffnet und jetzt
wird es natürlich wärmer man kann raus
gehen die kinder können draußen
trainieren es geht darum man versteht
das nicht wenn man noch nicht mal
draußen vielleicht die erwachsenen zu
zehn trainieren können die können die
matten auch zwei meter auseinander lägen
und keinen sport machen das eine ist
vielleicht dass man am ort 30 minuten
ein anstrengendes training macht
vielleicht ist das anstrengend der stadt
ein ein muskeltraining und ich glaube
wir haben das anliegen dann ja und das
hat mit öffnen hin und herren nichts zu
tun ich finde sport tatsächlich der
gehirn zum leben zu leben so in die
heiße ja und die disziplin dazu und das
darf eigentlich nie immer diskutiert
werden auf oder zu sondern sport gehört
zu unserem leben so und dann sind wir
bei karl lauterbach und fragen uns
natürlich noch mal mit dem gedanken den
wir zuletzt mit herrn bouffier
diskutiert haben ob es tatsächlich jetzt
an der zeit ist diese dinge alle wieder
zu ermöglichen oder befürchten sie herr
lauterbach das jetzt überall die raketen
schneiden dass die leute sagen jetzt
gucken wir mal übermorgen 50er incidents
und dann noch rauschen hinterher die
zahlen wiederum die modelle und ich weiß
noch mal daraufhin die modelle sind
wertvoll und lage nicht falsch sondern
also dass agiert das ist ein
es ist eingetreten was in den modellen
vorhergesagt wurde
wenn wir gegen reagieren das muss man
wirklich also weil ich ja wirklich die
im markt dieses wissenschaftler bashing
nicht das ist total kontraproduktiv
ich will bevor ich die konkrete frage
beantwortet bevor ich das vergessen noch
mal darauf hinweisen
wir haben früher den anderen fehler
gemacht also als die zweite welle kam
wir haben mit durch die erste welle sind
ihr großartig durchgekommen da haben wir
den wissenschaftlern vertrauter ist toll
gearbeitet worden als die zweite welle
kommt da haben wir genau das gegenteil
gab da kam dann wissenschaftlern ohne
modelle die haben an lockerungen sagen
dass alles gut und zweitens wird darauf
haben sich zu viele verlassen dann sind
wir von der zweiten welle so hart
erwischt worden dass wir die gute
gesamtbilanz an sterbefällen in
deutschland verloren haben die sind
jetzt auch noch nicht schlecht aber das
ist nur dem erfolg der ersten welle zu
verdanken
vor der zweiten welle ist zu wenig
gewarnt worden ich will hier keine namen
nennen aber wir wissen alle welche
wissenschaftler damals also uns in eine
falsche sicherheit gewogen haben das
darf man jetzt nicht vergessen
und wenn wir jetzt den fehler machen
würde
nach dem motto alles ist gut das ist hat
sich stabilisiert und so weiter und
sofort öffnen ruckzuck dann gibt es auch
jetzt wieder modelle die zeigen dass
dann die fallzahlen für diejenigen die
noch nicht geimpft sind hoch gehen ich
will das an einem beispiel erläutern wie
dramatisch dass sein garten stellen sie
sich mal vor es ist nur die hälfte der
bevölkerung geimpft die andere hälfte
noch nicht und wir hätten an incident
sie geht dann wieder ein bisschen hoch
und 200 die verteilt sich dann auf die
hälfte der bevölkerung die ist dann 400
für diejenigen die noch nicht geimpft
sind die haben das heißt diejenigen die
nicht geben denn die sind an einem
riesigen risiko und je kleiner die zahl
derer ist die nicht mehr geht der ist
nur noch nicht geimpft ist bei einer
desto größer ist ihr größter ist in
dieser gruppe und wir dürfen nicht die
kinder und die familien jetzt zurück
lassen sieben prozent der kinder das ist
unstrittig die sich infizieren
entwickeln lankowitz syndrom das ist
keine kleinigkeit die jüngeren erwarten
wir gleich noch darüber diskutieren
diese uns noch mal herr lauterbach da
kamen wir ja hier erstens woher
plötzlich diese neue situation weil die
ist ja so schnell nicht vorhergesehen
worden da ist ja jetzt auch der eine
oder andere wissenschaftler überrascht
wie viel und wie rasant es eine senkung
der zahlen geht es bis die musik ok also
sie können den kopf wegen aber ich mach
mal den gedanken zu ende
die frage ist jetzt natürlich
tatsächlich brauchen wir in dieser
situation nicht genau diese
modellversuche die in rostock und in
münster und in tübingen inzwischen
stattgefunden haben und hoffentlich in
potsdam und die wir so lange strikt
verboten haben brauchen wir nicht jetzt
genau deren evidenz weil wir jetzt
wieder andere zahlen haben dort wo die
also incidents unter 100 liegt da das
ist ja kein problem da ist das da kann
es ja schon gemacht werden aber ich will
auch folgenden umstand hinterlassen
bisher haben die impfungen nicht so toll
die rolle gespielt für die also
incidents um die runter zu bekommen aber
jetzt haben wir 30 prozent genau wissen
wie hier auf 40 50 prozent sind dann
fällt tatsächlich die incidents
exponentiell ab weil derjenige der
geimpfte ist er fällt erstmal aus als
jemand der andere ansteckt aber
gleichzeitig auch als jemand der
angesteckt werden
somit das was exponentiell wächst das
fährt auch wieder exponentiell abo
diesen kipp punkt werden wir ende mai
erreichen spätestens und dann gehen die
fahnen ganz deutlich runter das ist auch
was viola prise man vollkommen zurecht
hier also schon vorgetragen hat letzte
woche donnerstag genommen und somit und
ist habe ich eine ganz einfache
botschaft lassen sie uns doch noch wir
jetzt fast also wir haben ein jahr und
drei monate durch garten einem jahr vier
monate durchgehalten wollen wir nicht
doch diese drei wochen durchhalten um
dann den vollen genuss haben denn wie
dramatisch ist es wenn sich auf den
letzten wochen in die menschen die jetzt
auf den letzten wochen sich infizieren
und schwer krank werden das ist doch
nicht nötig daher ich würde dass ich
diese letzten drei wochen
da würde ich mich auf die
wissenschaftliche modelle verlassen wir
halt noch etwas durch
danach kam geöffnet werden dann brauche
ich auch gar keine großen modelle mehr
weil dann sinken die fallzahlen deutlich
ich kann dann auch die impf
geschwindigkeit erhöhen diese letzten
drei vier wochen in denen wir jetzt noch
etwas mäßigung brauchen da plädiere ich
nehmt doch diejenigen mittel jetzt noch
kann dem angebot haben können
und da ist die frage herr bouffier nickt
und wünscht sich hoffentlich dass es
genau so kommt wie herr lauterbach jetzt
prophezeit das wäre ja sehr schön über
die länge von bonitäten reden wir noch
wir sind bei frau büxt und fragen
wir sollten immer sehr vorsichtig sein
frau box wird es uns jetzt gelungen ein
bisschen vorsichtig zu sein
ich glaube schon wir haben in der
bevölkerung dieses sehr interessantes
phänomen gehabt das so februar die leute
wirklich keine lust mehr hatten und
eigentlich mehr von der politik wollten
da gab es auf einmal eine steigende zahl
von menschen die gesagt haben jetzt
macht mal richtig zu damit das endlich
vorbei ist und wir haben noch immer sehr
viel unterstützung dafür dass wir
maßnahmen haben so sehr die leute leiden
und so viele betroffen sind ich glaube
die wenigsten wollen das jetzt aufs
spiel setzen
und deswegen ich habe das gerade gehört
kontrolliert das stichwort mit mit
augenmaß mit einer gewissen vorsicht
aber alles natürlich mit einbeziehen was
wir haben wir haben nicht nur die
impfung wir haben auch erfahrungen mit
guten test konzepten
hygiene konzepten und wenn man das jetzt
schritt für schritt so zu sagen so macht
dass man nicht gegen das impfen quasi
beschnitt sondern mit dem impfen
ich glaube dann kriegen wir das hin das
ist wirklich nur noch eine kurze zeit
und heute ist ja auch eine neue
verordnung gekommen die ja auch sehr
interessant ist die auch wieder darauf
hinweist wenn man unter der 100 bleibt
sicher unter der 100 bleibt dann kann
man auch wieder für viele menschen
vieles sofort möglich machen ohne dass
man jetzt wirklich in diese risiken
rennt einer unkontrollierten öffnung ich
glaube das wünschen sich die wenigsten
und nun gab es heute ja auch eine
entscheidung im bundestag wer nämlich
doppelt geimpft ist für den wird es
sogar schon am wochenende einfacher und
darüber diskutieren wir gleich der turbo
scheint endlich zu zünden nach
schneckentempo start nimmt das impfen
fahrt auf für den pieks gibt es fortan
rechte zurück die neue bundesverordnung
soll schon ab dem wochenende gelten
rechtsstaatliche grundsätze gelten nicht
nur in normalzeiten sondern sie müssen
gerade auch in krisenzeiten geld keine
kontakt beschränkungen mehr shoppen ohne
test all das freut die geimpften droht
ungeimpfte aber zu vergrätzen
freiheitsrechte versus gleichbehandlung
ganze branchen liegen derweil weiter
brach denn ins restaurant oder hotel
können auch geimpfte vorerst nicht ohne
grund findet die opposition
wir sind uns sicher dass eine öffnung
von kultur und sportstätten für geimpfte
und genesen in vielen bereichen möglich
ist vor allen dingen kann die
außengastronomie mit schutz konzepten
geöffnet werden allerdings gibt es
wieder die verbrecher schleswig-holstein
öffnet in zehn tagen komplett für den
tourismus test oder impfung
vorausgesetzt bayern kündigt erste
lockerungen zu pfingsten an wo es unter
100 ist geben wir und wollen wir die
möglichkeit schaffen die insbesondere
bei ferien zu ermöglichen
mecklenburg vorpommern ist da viel
vorsichtiger nur geimpfte erwachsene
werden für tagesausflüge geduldet droht
auch beim öffnen wieder chaos
da er sich zusätzlich darf es laut sagen
sie haben gerade schon über markus söder
gesprochen der gestern noch als erster
zu machen wollte jetzt will als erster
auf machen nur um dem armin zu zeigen
dass er schneller ist als er
wie heißt das spiel also das glaube ich
nicht wir haben verzeigung muss man ja
mal sagen ich kenne niemanden der jetzt
los rennt und völlig ungebremst alles
öffnen will ist ja die falsche debatte
es wird dabei bleiben dass wir die
hygieneregeln einhalten müssen dass wir
die masken halten müssen das ist auch
vernünftig das glaube ich machen die
leute auch mit
dann ist die frage wie man stück für
stück sich vernünftig nach vorne bewegt
kann ja das ist er noch nicht wirklich
brauchen
das ist auch richtig schauen sie die
menschen die bundesjustizministerin
völlig recht die menschen haben ihre
grundrechte und vor anderthalb jahren
hätte uns jeder für verrückt erklärt
wenn wir den sagen passt mal auf wir
machen jetzt regeln wie viele leuten du
dich noch treffen kannst und module ist
oder ein gegensatz der wahnsinnig ist
meine freiheit
die kann man einschränkend bei
überragenden gründen des allgemeinwohls
wie so schön heißt nur dann und erkennt
von allem ist immer wenn eine gefahr
ausgeht wenn die gefahr nicht mehr da
ist dann die grundrechte wieder in kraft
setzen
so klar wie kloßbrühe das macht das
haben sie hervorragend auch juristisch
für argumentiert hat die politik heute
auch deshalb so schnell reagiert und
morgen dann auch im bundesrat so schnell
reagiert um sich die blamage vor dem
bundesverfassungsgericht zu ersparen
ich habe mich im bundesrat zu den
verfassungsrechtlichen fragen geäußert
und ich hatte das als ultima ratio mit
der ausgangssperre gemacht ich will
jetzt nicht spekulieren
wir müssen ja das was wir tun aus
eigener überzeugung machen und da hilft
dann war oder schadet in
anführungsstrichen aus politischer sicht
ein urteil aber am ende tragen wird
diese verantwortung und das heißt die
aus als hätten sie nicht gemacht wir
haben sie in hessen ja gehabt
er hat mir schon längst wir haben sie
aber anders vor
und ich hatte den kollegen das auch
empfohlen das ist dann in einem sehr
schnellen prozess nicht so gekommen
ich will es nicht zu juristisch machen
wenn sie das als ultima ratio von ihr
nach dem motto wenn sonst alles hat mich
wirklich greifen indem sie zum beispiel
belebte plätze ein betretungsverbot
machen damit sie am ufer
betretungsverbot machen also überall wo
erfahren wo viele menschen sind wenn das
alles nicht hilft dank dann können sie
auch so was machen das gesetz was wir
jetzt haben setzt einfach fest so ist es
da gibt es keine abwägung und bei den
grundrechten sind immer abwägungen
vorzunehmen das wird das
verfassungsgericht jetzt zu beurteilen
haben lassen wir mal stehen entscheidend
ist mir folgendes wir haben einmal die
die die grundrechtliche lage und ich
glaube dass niemand ernsthaft bestreitet
wenn die gefahr nicht mehr da ist dann
muss müssen gerechnet so behandeln wie
sie immer träger der grundrechte sehen
jetzt sind wir in einer zwischenphase es
ist eben sehr schön gesagt wurden
übrigens dass die menschen das alles gut
finden oder da bin ich sehr vorsichtig
geht um fragen von heute 51 prozent sind
dagegen dass jemand jetzt negativ
getesteten gleichgestellt wird und 48
sind irgendwie dafür
ich mache die erfahrung der kreis derer
die zufrieden sind mit dem was wir da
machen wird kleiner und zwar aus ganz
unterschiedlichen gründen nicht nehmen
wir das beispiel schule
da gibt es die einen die mir schreiben
dass wir ihre kinder dem tode war hin
weil wir schule öffnen und die anderen
die sagen ob wirklich begriffen hätten
dass wir eine ganze generation dauerhaft
schädigen wenn wir die nicht war wieder
nicht alle lassen
beide sind aus völlig unterschiedlichen
dem fall sogar gegensätzlichen
positionen nicht zufrieden mit dem was
wir tun und wenn sie dann bestimmte
sektoren abfragen dann kriegen sie immer
so irgendeine scheibchen antwort die
grundsituation ist eine andere
wir müssen jetzt über einen ganz
spannende zeit noch kommen das ist sich
auch und wir haben eine regelung swiss
musste für gut oder schlecht halten bis
zum 30 juni gilt die sind nicht nur die
banken
das heißt unter 100 können wir
entscheiden und dann werden wir testen
und ich denke die anderen werden das
auch so machen ich dass nächste woche
waren
wir werden jetzt nicht sagen okay alles
wie früher sondern wir werden sagen das
entscheidende wirklich ist doch nicht
eine inzidenz zahl sondern das
entscheidende für mich ist dass vor ort
dass sie jene konzept das das test
konzept funktioniert dann kann man auch
mehr machen
und da ist mein eindruck da herrscht
eine große bereitschaft zu sagen sie
haben das beispiel genannt mit dem
fitnessstudio ist das habe ich damals
gemacht und gesagt anmeldung lose test
und ewiges und da soll mal sieben in
hessen mit vielen sowieso vor der zeit
sie haben auch diese gleichbehandlung
jetzt von geimpften und gelesenen früher
eingeführt
und sie haben auch astrazeneca früher
und nicht mehr priorisiert sie wollen
aber nicht kanzler werden herr bouffier
nein ich bin sehr zufrieden mit dem was
ich hier sind auf der geografisch linken
seite und und fragen uns herr lauterbach
getestete genesene geimpfte die sollen
gleich behandelt werden da ist der
mediziner aber überhaupt nicht dabei
oder weil natürlich ein getesteter viel
weniger weniger geschützt ist das ist
richtiger so medizinisches der
unterschied natürlich groß derjenige der
folge ist also die vollständige impfung
hat der ist also mit sehr viel höherer
wahrscheinlichkeit für andere nicht mehr
ansteckend und kann sich auch nicht mehr
anstecken
als jemand der gerade ein antigen test
gehabt hat weil die anti gen tests sind
sie gut gemacht sind entdecken nur
ungefähr 60 prozent der infizierten das
haus tatsächlich ist der test nicht so
toll
daher sind die test konzepte ich auch
alles so gemacht dass ständig getestet
wird also zweimal die woche getestet war
damit kann ich mir das leisten wenn ich
jemanden beim ersten mal übersehen habe
ich ihn beim nächsten mal aber somit ist
das medizinisch ein riesenunterschied
trotzdem ist es so jetzt für die zwecke
um die es hier geht beispielsweise zum
friseur zu gehen das wartungs wort da
kann man das riskieren dann kann man
sagen dass setzen wir hier gleich weil
derjenige der jetzt wegen durch den
antigen test nicht entdeckt ist obwohl
er positiv ist der infiziert in der
regel dann nur noch einen aber nicht
sehr viele die
also positiven übersee sind der regel
kann so genannten super klasse und genau
keine klasse also mit kann man das
einigermaßen machen
ich wollte einen satz noch zu ihnen herr
profil sagen was nicht vergessen werden
darf einer der gründe weshalb wir
sozusagen so streng deshalb die
wissenschaftler die meisten
wissenschaftler es gibt solche und
solche aber dann darfst nicht so
darstellen als wenn alle gleich
nebeneinander stimmung sondern der
konsens der wissenschaftler die
sozusagen renommiert publizieren und als
im stoff gelten auch unter kollegen die
sind alle dafür dass wir jetzt noch mal
sehr vorsichtig sind mit den fallzahlen
dass wir die fahrzeuge nur unterdrücken
eben weil diese unter 50 unter 50 und
zwar deshalb weil nichts ist
gefährlicher als bei teilweise geimpften
haben eine impfung und montage
bevölkerung ist die hohe zahl zu haben
war dann lade ich mutationen ins land
und wir haben alle vor einer situation
angst die jetztige ähnliche 100 die ist
nicht wirklich so gefährlich also was in
indien sich abspielt diese tragödie hat
mit der indischen mutation zu tun aber
das ist nicht das hauptproblem aber in
indien ist der zorn situation da sind so
viele infiziert und so wenig schutz und
es wird zu wenig pcr getestet und so
wenige sequenzen dass ich dort noch ganz
andere mutationen bilden können und wenn
du jetzt uns rüberkommen nach europa in
ein teilweise geimpftes europa wo ich 30
prozent ginster habe aber davon zwei
drittel nur einmal geimpft
die us serie wirklich gefehlt und wir
wollen den erfolg nicht gefährden indem
wir jetzt in den wochen wo wir sehr
schnell impfen sehr hohe fallzahlen
haben das ist der grund weshalb auch ich
hoffe dass das bundesverfassungsgericht
und heute endgültigen beurteilung des
falles uns da recht gibt in der
gesamtschau sind das jetzt ganz
kritische wochen wenn wir erstmal weit
über werden wir weit über 50 prozent
gegen tagen haben wir eine andere seiner
kollegen sondern sieht und dann reden
wir trotzdem darüber dass und wie sehr
es wichtig wäre eigentlich der ganzen
welt zu helfen ja und nicht nur europa
das haben wir hier schon thematisiert
ich versuche jetzt nochmal mit einem
haken muss zurück zu unserem thema
comics wir sind bei den geimpften bei
den getesteten und bei den
und da sagen sie worin muss jetzt
eigentlich wären recht bestehen und
welches recht dürfen sie nicht haben
sollen die alle jetzt wahnsinnig
vorsichtig sein eben weil so viele noch
nicht geimpft genesen sind manche aber
schon gelöst das würde ich gern vielen
dank einmal kurz auf trösel auch in
reaktion auf das was er bouffier gerade
gesagt hat also wären vom deutschen
ethikrat auch gesagt wenn wenn es je
sicherer es ist dass geimpfte nicht mehr
andere anstecken können und dass wir uns
nicht mehr weiter tragen desto eher muss
man diese harten einschränkung aufheben
also quarantäne ist ein super beispiel
umgekehrt haben wir gesagt die masten
pflicht abstand halten das sind keine so
harten freiheitsbeschränkung wenn wir
das noch brauchen können wir das auch
den gf noch ein bisschen so muten die
gleichstellung geimpft getestet genesen
auch wenn die risiken unterschiedlich
sind ist aber aus ethischer perspektive
positiv zu beurteilen weil das bedeutet
dass die noch nicht geimpften und nicht
genesen
ein zugang kriegen so und dann bleibt
ein bereich übrig nämlich die kontakt
beschränkung ausnahmen von der ausgangs
beschränkung und so weiter da werden wir
eine soziale spannung haben werden wir
einen großteil der bevölkerung haben
noch die einfach zurückgetreten ist für
diejenigen die jetzt schon geimpft sind
und das ist keine neiddebatte das ist
mir ganz wichtig da geht es tatsächlich
sozusagen um zurücktreten dass man getan
hat für andere und einer art doppelten
nachteil dem man dadurch hand und ich
wünsche mir da von der politik dass das
anerkannt wird denn das betrifft vor
allem die junge generation die jetzt
wirklich noch eine lange weile warten
muss von allen letztlich am längsten die
etwas mitgemacht hat und ich wünsche mir
habe heute auch eine agentur von ihnen
dazu gelesen kollege von ihnen im
ethikrat plädiert dafür dass man auch
junge menschen jugendliche impft weil
die schon so lange so
solidarisch war also man könnte auch
über diese priorisierung natürlich
nachdenken was sagen sie
das wird also da gibt es intensive
diskussionen im moment also wir sagen
bescheid wenn die jetzt die noch ist
diese priorisierung sinnvoll und wichtig
weil noch gibt es einfach menschen mit
diesen doch deutlich erhöhten risiken
aber bald haben die allen angebot gehabt
dann kann diese priorisierung auslaufen
und ich muss sagen dann habe ich sehr
viel sympathie für vorschläge die sagen
lasst uns ganz in die breite gehen lasst
uns ganz auf suchend impfen lass uns da
wo sozusagen soziale brennpunkte gibt wo
die leute ganz eng zusammen wohnen
impfen lass uns aber auch die jungen
impfen
denn die haben einfach viel sich
solidarisch zurückgenommen
die hatten selber lange lange zeit viel
niedrigere risiken als die die besonders
gefährdet waren
und mir geht es einfach darum bei aller
berechtigung dieses juristischen
argumente
das haben mir meine kollegen im ethikrat
natürlich auch gesagt da sitzen auch
hervorragende juristen auch
verfassungsjuristen das ist etwas was
ich was ich wirklich wichtig finde dass
es anerkannt wird dass man da angebote
schafft für diejenigen die jetzt noch
eine ganze weile das aushalten müssen
ein letzter satz mehr ist solidarisch
mit den soliden